une autre nuit d'enfer à Manille et une
autre scène de crime de cadavres
deux jeunes gangster abattus par les
flics après un braquage dans une
fusillade qui a réveillé tout le
voisinage
je vois ces incidents comme une chose
ordinaire
pourtant cette scène de crime n'est pas
si ordinaire j'apprends que deux autres
gangsters ont été emmenés à l'hôpital et
sont morts avant d'y arriver et sans
mettre plus loin il y a le cadavre du 5e
gangster de la bande
ça y est j'arrive à Manille au fond de
l'océan Pacifique
une bien belle ville vu d'ici lovée au
bord d'une vaste baie
la porte d'entrée des Philippines 7107
îles des plages et du soleil une
destination de rêve
à condition de ne pas rester à Manille
je ne connais pas cette ville mais je
sais qu'à la mauvaise réputation
Manille la capitale des Philippines une
mégalopole brouillante d'au moins 12
millions d'habitants peut-être 15
personnes ne sait vraiment une jungle
urbaine écrasée par la moiteur tropicale
étouffée par des embouteillages monstres
et une pollution suffocante
Manille capitale d'un des pays les plus
démunis d'Asie 100 millions de
Philippins dont un tiers en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté Manille une cité
d'inégalité criante ou émerge des îlots
d'une richesse insolente
ou partout s'incruste des bidonvilles
les cicatrices à vif d'une pauvreté
chronique
Amani je vais découvrir le crime dans
tous ses états
[Musique]
je vais y voir des assassinations
une police brutale et décrié une justice
débordée
des citoyens engagés au péril de leur
vie
je vais voir des enfants livrés à la rue
les ravages de la drogue
les talages de la prostitution mais je
vais aussi rencontrer des gens
formidables ils vont être mes guides
comme bénigne le photoporteur de faits
divers
de la presse tabloïde bénigne arpente
depuis 26 ans les bas-fonds de Manille
je vais admirer de Malou la bénévole de
Caritas qui se démène pour que les
enfants des bidonvilles échappent à la
criminalité
je vais approcher le général Espinal
nouveau patron de la police de Manille
faire de l'anse de la lutte
anti-corruption
et je vais apprendre ce qu'est une
arrestation musclée
je vais être touché par les confessions
de Bing la mer maquerelle qui raconte la
détresse des prostituées
je vais suivre les combats d'Erwin turfo
le journaliste sans concession qui
pourchasse les crimes petits et grands
et qui pourfant en direct à la
télévision les abus des puissants
et pour clore mon séjour je vais échouer
dans la plus grande prison du pays mais
pour une simple visite
bienvenue à Manille avec en poche un
passeport pour le crime
quand la nuit tombe à Manille la ville
Bruce de ce qu'elle a de pire
cette nuit là j'ai mon premier
rendez-vous au commissariat principal de
Manille pas pour voir les flics mais
pour rencontrer les journalistes ce qui
ne travaillent que la nuit justement
c'est pas un hasard si leur bureau est
dans l'enceinte même du commissariat
leur truc c'est les crimes et les Faits
Divers Ici on les appelle les polices
bits reporters
[Musique]
surnommé bénigne et aux Philippines tout
le monde s'appelle par son surnom
[Musique]
est le plus ancien des journalistes de
faits divers ça fait 26 ans qu'il ne
dort plus la nuit
une fois en une seule nuit j'ai vu 16
mon record 16 score
c'était il y a trois mois
quand on nous signale une scène de crime
il y a une compétition avec les
policiers
la police scientifique et les autres
agences on doit être rapide
il faut bouger plus vite que
les cadavres avant qu'on arrive il n'y a
plus de reportage possible
[Rires]
ce sont des moments très excitants
pour ma première nuit à Manille bingo il
y a eu un meurtre dans la ville ce n'est
pas attendu plus d'une heure
la troupe des polices Beach porter ses
branle je monte avec bénigne
[Musique]
c'est en convoie que nous nous dirigeons
vers les lieux du crime pour ne pas se
tromper il suffit de suivre la voiture
des flics
arrivée à destination le quartier de
tondeau près du port les voitures ne
vont pas plus loin
et nous entrons dans l'un des bidons
villes les plus dangereux de ma vie
[Musique]
fais attention tu marches
Benning m'entraîne dans un dédale de
Ruelle crasseuse un an je vais être ment
de tôle de planche et de parpaing le
genre d'endroit où ni les journalistes
ni la police ne s'aventurent la nuit
d'ordinaire
sauf quand il y a un cadavre à ramasser
il a quel âge
29 ans
la scène de crime est accessible à tous
médias et Badoo une vraie opération
porte ouverte
bénigne a vite fait de débriefer les
flics pauvre gâche chauffeur de
triporteur de son état a été abattu par
trois hommes deux balles de 9 mm tirées
à bout portant une douille a déjà
disparue celle qui restent précieusement
conservé dans un emballage de bonbons
[Musique]
la femme de la victime ne s'est rien à
rien vu n'a aucune idée sur les
assassins la police plateau
trois hommes ont surgi je ne sais pas
pour quelle motif
alors que la victime jouait à pile ou
face avec d'autres gens
ont tiré deux balles ce sont enfuis et
laisser le jeune homme étendu comme ça
c'est clair c'est une erreur
erreur sur la personne impossible de
savoir pas témoin pas de mobile apparent
et ici la police n'est pas la bienvenue
elle doit calmer la foule avant
d'emporter le corps
on ne fait qu'appliquer la procédure
c'est la loi
si vous ne voulez pas qu'on autopsie le
corps venez le prendre vous-même à la
mort c'est gratuit
si vous ne vouliez pas qu'on enquête il
fallait le ramasser avant et l'emmener
chez vous ou chez le croque-mort
[Musique]
un meurtre dans un bidonville une nuit
banale pour bénir
on retourne au bureau
[Musique]
les reporters de faits divers c'est un
scénario qui se répète chaque nuit aux
Philippines
vous voyez tout autour c'est un quartier
défavorisé un bidonville
ici chaque petit altercation peut se
terminer en crime
le problème c'est que personne ne peut
parler ou dénoncer les assassins car ils
doivent penser à protéger leur vie
on rentre et on attend le prochain coup
[Musique]
bénigne retravaille ses clichés pour les
envoyer à son journal Le Crime ça peut
payer tant qu'il y a des Photoshop
[Musique]
ces photos sont assez brutales
parce que ceux qui lisent les journaux
ce sont les gens du peuple
les pauvres ce qui habite dans les
bidonville
alors quand c'est trop dur il y a moyen
de ne pas montrer tout ce sang parfois
on fout l'image
beding batugas travaille pour nayon un
journal tabloïde cette presse à grands
tirage qui prospère à Manille une
quarantaine de ces journaux font chaque
jour surenchères de sexe et de sang seul
littérature ou presque du peuple
Amani le Quotidien du peuple se sont
aussi les Jeep days et minibus bariolets
construit à base de vieilles jeep
américaine le transport local
un vrai tapis pas vraiment écolo mais
bien pratique pour déjouer les
embouteillages
[Musique]
assister au combat de coq me rencarde
aussi pas mal sur cette société fervente
et bruyante dans ce pays du tiers-monde
c'est l'une des attractions les plus
populaires avec la boxe
les meilleurs coques naissent aux
États-Unis on fait venir les oeufs des
États-Unis jusqu'ici
[Applaudissements]
les coques sont préparées-elles des
athlètes pour le combat leur ergo et
prolongé d'une lame acérée ici pas
d'affrontement sans mise à mort
avant chaque duel le spectacle gagne les
gradins c'est à celui qui parrira sur le
vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
c'est difficile de comprendre votre
système de Paris non c'est très simple
[Applaudissements]
drôle de rituel par geste chaque parieur
désigne son favoris au bookmaker qui
retiennent tout sans droit à l'erreur
plusieurs milliers de dollars peuvent
être parié sur un seul combat
[Applaudissements]
gladiateurs à plumes les coqs offrent
leur vie en exutoire des passions
humaines la violence et la mort on
dirait bien qu'ils ont ça dans le sang
Philippe
Amani l'univers du crime offre un
spectacle chaotique
pas de mafia organisée mais des gangs
prêts à tout
des armes à profusion
des faits divers sanglants qui boostent
les audiences des télévisions
une criminalité débordante sauvage vole
un armer assassinat viol et la dernière
tendance les carnappings les attaques de
voitures
[Musique]
le Carna ping un nouvel artisanat du
crime qui détrône celui du kidnapping
[Musique]
architecte d'origine chinoise est l'un
des derniers kidnappés célèbre de
Manille libérée par la police après 17
jours dans la
une expérience qui le marque encore
aujourd'hui
oui
c'était en septembre 2008 je rentrais
chez moi quand j'étais enlevé par quatre
à six hommes dans plusieurs voitures
enchaîné bâillonner
menotté de la tête aux pieds
au matin du 17e jour j'ai entendu des
portes claquées décrit des coups de feu
sentir deux ou trois personnes qui
m'attrapaient et qui m'entraînait de mon
cachot
un moment le plus angoissant car je ne
savais pas si ces personnes étaient des
bons ou des méchants qui voulaient
m'utiliser comme bouclier humain
l'empire du crime inspire l'une des
émissions les plus populaires de la
télévision Philippines
[Musique]
l'émission s'appelle Soko Soco comme le
sigle de la police scientifique et son
présentateur vedette c'est Ghost
sabelgas
[Musique]
depuis 10 ans gosse abelgas rassemble
chaque semaine des millions de
téléspectateurs en reconstituant un
crime qui a marqué les esprits
je retrouve Ghost sur le terrain dans un
village de la banlieue de Manille
c'est venu interviewer la grand-mère
d'une jeune fille violée et tuée par son
voisin le jour de Noël il y a à peine un
an
quand ma fille est revenue du poste de
police
elle m'a confirmé la mort de ma petite
fille
la police avait déjà retrouvé le corps
vous avez vu le corps est-ce qu'elle
était comme ça oui je l'ai vu elle était
prostrée non elle était sur le ventre
elle était face contre terre
la jeune fille violée assassinée
s'est-elle adding elle n'avait que 12
ans
adding était une écolière modèle son
meurtre par son voisin et a mis à
choquer les Philippins
gosse un drôle de boulot faire péter
l'audimat en exploitant les crimes les
plus sordides sans compassion apparente
mais je vais découvrir qu'il n'est pas
si insensible
elle n'avait que 12 ans
quand le crime a été commis
la violence domestique c'est un vrai
problème aux Philippines
et au manque d'éducation
et c'est vrai spécialement chez ce genre
de famille
ils vivent les uns sur les autres
[Musique]
ces gens n'ont pas assez d'éducation dès
qu'ils ont une frustration
il réagissent en fonction de leurs
instincts
[Applaudissements]
le succès de Soco fait le bonheur des
billets sibiennes la principale chaîne
du pays
gassambelgas ne se contente pas de
raconter les affaires criminelles il
veut aider à les résoudre et pour cela
il n'hésite pas à faire appel au public
[Musique]
une simple querelle qui s'envenime
conduit parfois au meurtre
si seulement les personnes impliquées
dans ce drame avaient eu plus de sang
froid aucune vie n'aurait été perdue
pendant ce temps un suspect se cache
encore
si vous avez des informations sur Joseph
Korea Alvarez dit Jojo appeler la
hotline de BBS
pour une nouvelle enquête au service de
la vérité
Soco scène de crime je suis gusabelgas
et je vous souhaite un bon après-midi
[Musique]
ici la télé fait parfois le travail de
la police une autre conception du
journalisme
[Musique]
et puis vous devez
on montre au public que telle personne
est recherchée pour tel que c'est encore
mieux quand les autorités offrent une
récompense pour son arrestation
de la personne recherchée à la
télévision on reçoit plein d'appels du
public
et on est fier d'être l'une des
émissions qui aide à la résolution des
crimes
c'est une sorte de service public pour
nous
et que pensez-vous de la police ici
font de leur mieux
mais malheureusement one et c'est
d'ailleurs le problème numéro 1 il y a
beaucoup de crimes ici aux Philippines
où ironiquement des policiers sont
impliqués
la police des Philippines
au commissariat de Manille la police
joue la transparence les gradés sont
tout fiers d'exposer leur nouvelle
équipements Antibes un don de
l'ambassade des États-Unis
et une façon de combler leur cruellement
de moyens
c'est quoi c'est une fibre optique vous
pouvez regarder par ici chef
le gros problème de la police c'est la
faiblesse de ses effectifs 18000
fonctionnaires pour toute la métropole
de Manille soit à peine un flic pour 600
habitants 4 fois moins qu'à Paris
pour entrer dans les cuisines de la
police je ne peux avoir meilleur
entremetteurs que bénigne il est comme
chez lui au commissariat
visite chez ses potes de la brigade
criminelle ici
Belling rentre sans frapper
ne porte pas l'uniforme
le bureau des homicides est une section
très importante au quartier général
en attendant que leur cas soit traité
surprise un couple de touristes français
a échoué ici victime de pickpocket
bienvenue à Manille
[Musique]
deux gros sacs évidemment j'avais mon
portefeuille et on était un gymne bien
et il y avait trois personnes qui sont
montées vous commencez un peu à s'amuser
et pour gagner notre confiance on va
dire et chercher des pièces de monnaie
sous mon siège et là un moment voilà
c'est parti ils sont partis à un arrêt
un stop qui sont barrés à trois j'ai
encore mon passeport ça c'est cool mais
j'ai pas ma carte de crédit et j'ai pas
300 euros
l'un des pickpockets est arrêté l'argent
volé ne sera pas retrouvé
[Musique]
ce soir là Benning couvre une action
coup de poing de la police baptisé
opération saturation plusieurs dizaines
d'agents ça prête à faire une descente
dans un quartier populaire
[Musique]
nous allons faire appliquer un arrêté
municipal une loi locale pour prévenir
l'apparition d'activité criminelles
dans un secteur où il y a souvent des
agressions les vols
toutes sortes de délits
la police va cerner tout un quartier
pour surprendre les jeunes qui traînent
dans la rue Caramanie il y a un
couvre-feu pour les mineurs interdit de
sortir entre 22h et 4h du matin la
police n'est pas seule les volontaires
de la municipalité sont venus en renfort
armé de Cannes et de bâtons
alors
une part d'un côté l'autre moitié arrive
par l'autre côté et on ramasse tous ceux
qui boivent et ceux qui sont torse nu
d'accord
l'objectif un gros quartier du sud de
Manille
les forces de l'ordre se divisent en
deux groupes chacun avance par l'une des
extrémités de l'artère principale
c'est ça l'opération saturation
les flics interpellent ceux qui boivent
dans la rue les mineurs qui ne
respectent pas le couvre-feu uniquement
les hommes pas des filles
180 jeunes sont ainsi invités selon la
terminologie des flics à se rassembler
dans un gymnase une sorte de rafle mais
plutôt bonne enfance la police n'est pas
toujours aussi cool
en fait son image est détestable brutale
corrompue mal équipé mal formé mal payé
[Musique]
une police philippine plutôt réputée
pour son inefficacité
pas vraiment du genre qui inspire
confiance
alors ce soir l'opération saturation est
d'abord une opération de comme avec la
complicité bienveillante de bénigne
les jeunes ne sont fouillés que pour la
forme leur identité contrôlée sous le
regard de leur famille qui peuvent leur
apporter leur papier
[Applaudissements]
ça permet de contrebalancer certains
agissements de la police
et les images de brutalité policières
c'est le meilleur moyen de montrer au
public qu'ils sont entre de bonnes mains
et sous contrôle
pour les jeunes pas de malaise ce n'est
pas leur premier contrôle pour les
policiers c'est l'occasion de sortir
leurs ordinateurs portables et d'activer
leur base de données l'informatique
nouvelle arme anti crime
s'est échappé d'un centre de détention
et de réhabilitation pour jeunes
ça sort de la base de données de
l'ordinateur
[Musique]
autre résultat concrets un groupe
d'hommes qui buvait de la bière dans la
rue
ceux qui boivent on les met à part parce
qu'on va établir une procédure contre
ils ont un frein la loi il est interdit
de boire dans les lieux publics donc on
les arrête et on va les mettre en
cellules et ceux qui sont torse nu
ceux qui sont torse nu c'est interdit on
les arrête aussi
quelques bouteilles de bière un jeune
fugueur et des lycéens pris en photo
pour nourrir la base de données
les 180 jeunes peuvent rentrer chez eux
un show sécuritaire pour les riverains
et pour le moral des flics
surtout le crime de rue
on poursuit l'objectif de la police
avoir une société propre et libre
du crime libre de toutes les atrocités
[Musique]
si la société philippine poursuit un
idéal il est certainement très chrétien
Jésus est la Vierge Marie sont
omniprésents dans ce pays à plus de 80%
catholiques
héritage de trois siècles de
colonisation espagnole
une église qui prêche les vertus
familiales et la non-violence mais aussi
une église très riche dans un pays très
pauvre
ce matin j'ai rendez-vous à la paroisse
Notre-Dame de la Paix au cœur de Manille
ici je dois rencontrer Malou
Malou et bénévoles pour Caritas une ONG
catholique qui vient en aide aux pauvres
elle m'embarque d'emblée pour une virée
en triporteur le taxi du peuple
[Musique]
malum emmène vers son lieu de travail le
quartier de tondeau près du port là où
règne la plus forte concentration de
bidonville de Manille qui en contrait
400 à 500 éparpillés dans toute la
mégalopole
ce bidonville là s'appelle paroles
[Musique]
à peine passer l'entrée je réalise que
je suis déjà venu ici mais c'était de
nuit
[Musique]
Malou s'enfonce sans hésiter dans ce
labyrinthe elle il vient chaque jour
depuis six ans tout le monde semble la
connaître
d'un jeu c'est dangereux de venir ici la
nuit
[Musique]
non vraiment la plupart d'entre eux sont
bons même si beaucoup de gens disent
qu'ils sont mauvais qu'ils sont des
tueurs
que je viens ici faire du travail social
je n'ai jamais eu peur
ce que je sais que Malou ne peut pas me
dire c'est que dans ces bidonvilles
prospère tous les trafics drogue
prostitution mais aussi trafiquants ou
même d'organes une zone déprimée comme
on dit aux Philippines à part ola plus
de 60 000 personnes entassées sur 20
hectares qui survivent avec moins de 2
euros par jour et par famille
[Musique]
sans au courant sans hygiène sans
travail ou presque
[Musique]
Nalou est pratiquement la seule à
apporter une aide extérieure
[Musique]
voilà une de leurs sources de revenus
de l'ail
ils épluent des gousses d'ail comme ça
ici un kilo d'ail est plus cher à porte
à peine 10 centimes
[Musique]
pourquoi est ton bébé est tout nu parce
que je vais lui donner son bain
[Musique]
mais toi pourquoi tu es pieds nus
ici Malou s'occupe des femmes et surtout
des enfants elle apporte ses conseils
son soutien mais aussi de la nourriture
et des médicaments
[Musique]
comment tu les prends ces médicaments
j'ai des problèmes pour respirer c'est
pour ça que j'en ai besoin
il y a pas docteur ici
et surtout pas d'argent pour acheter des
médicaments
c'est pour ça que je le rende pour qu'il
se soigne
où est ton enfant celui qui était tout
maigre
il est déjà décédé
et l'autre le petit
il est mort aussi
[Musique]
on trouve de tout à part là et bien sûr
une église enfin une chapelle
[Musique]
comme partout aux Philippines la
religion s'est aussi l'interdiction de
l'avortement et du divorce la
contraception quasi inaccessible
résultat une démographie galopante
surtout chez les plus pauvres ici chaque
famille fait en moyenne 8 enfants
il y a beaucoup d'enfants ici oui
beaucoup
c'est une vraie usine à enfant
ils vont à l'école
ici seulement la moitié des enfants va à
l'école
les autres restent ici
et quand ils ont 15 ou 17 ans il se
marie s'installe ici où il construisent
leur maison
et c'est pour ça que c'est si peuplé
ils n'ont pas de travail alors il reste
ici
grandir dans un bidonville laisse peu de
chance d'en sortir les enfants de parole
à ont au moins Malou
pour un peu d'aide et un peu d'espoir
[Musique]
Amani d'autres ont moins de chance
comme ses enfants des Russes saisis par
les caméras de la ville
pieds nus il s'élance sur leur proie des
taxis coincés dans les embouteillages
[Musique]
de menu larcin une prise de risque
maximum une vie d'enfants traquée
[Musique]
certains se font rattraper
jérémy a été arrêté pour vol il vient
d'un bidonville il a 13 ans trop jeune
pour la prison il est confié au
travailleur sociaux
[Musique]
mon père est mort ma mère est malade
personne ne peut s'occuper de mes frères
et sœurs
combien de frères et sœurs cette frères
et sœurs c'est qui l'aîné moi
ici après un vol mais quand je l'ai
interrogé il n'a pas admis sa
culpabilité
il dit qu'il a été entraîné
cinq enfants ont été arrêtés avec lui et
tout son y est le vol
tu vis de quoi je fais du commerce
quelle sorte de commerce
je ramasse des choses en plastique
je les revends
et je donne l'argent à ma mère
mais pourquoi tu voulais aller avec
cette bande
[Musique]
prévenir la délinquance lutter contre la
pauvreté vaste programme pour les
travailleurs sociaux de Manille
chaque vendredi soir ils partent en
maraude à la pêche aux enfants des rues
[Musique]
premier arrêt toute une famille est
surprise à dormir dans un abri de
fortune à même le trottoir c'est
interdit par arrêter municipal
Rodriguez Ramos et son équipe de
travailleurs sociaux doivent les
embarquer c'est leur job
[Musique]
on vient pour les sauver
ils sont dans la rue et ils n'ont pas de
maison
on veut les prendre avec nous pour les
protéger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a une plante de la mairie contre
les gens qui salissent la voie publique
venez avec nous monter
n'ayez pas peur
c'est pour vous aider
[Musique]
la mère des enfants a réussi à se
défiler contre la promesse de venir les
récupérer plus tard
le père résiste il a des problèmes
psychiatriques il faut le faire monter
de force
maintenant tu te calmes
ils savent très bien qu'il viole la loi
mais pourtant ils insistent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là il est encore des enfants
la nuit les enfants n'ont pas le droit
d'être seul dans la rue ils sont
considérés comme abandonnés leurs
parents s'ils en ont devant les
récupérer
on a déjà nettoyé cet endroit à l'année
dernière et pourtant il revienne les
mêmes oui les mêmes mais ça nous empêche
pas de faire notre travail on continuera
jusqu'à ce qu'on y arrive
[Musique]
mais ma mère est juste là qu'est-ce que
tu faisais dans la rue je faisais rien
j'étais juste en train de jouer à côté
de chez moi
ne pleure pas sinon la police va venir
[Musique]
les enfants sont emmenés au centre
social de la ville de Manille regroupé
avec les SDF ramassés ce soir là
[Musique]
pour remplir son dossier
tu as quel âge
coincé entre des consignes répressives
et le manque de moyens les 40 malheureux
travailleurs sociaux de manif font ce
qu'ils peuvent pour endiguer la
délinquance
certains d'entre eux à cause de la
pauvreté ce sont des criminels en
puissance
les enfants que nous avons sauvés ce
soir sont parfois utilisés pour faire
des hold-ups ou des vols
nous devons protéger ses enfants
les enfants vont être hébergés ici au
moins pour la nuit
distribution de bonbons pour les
réconforter avant de les nourrir et de
les laver
[Musique]
il n'y a que 200 places dans ce centre
les enfants n'iraient pas plus de deux
semaines si leur mère ne vient pas les
chercher avec la preuve qu'ils ont un
logement ils seront placés dans d'autres
institutions
[Musique]
les nuits sont bien longues à Manille
et mes journées plutôt chargées
j'ai encore un paquet de rendez-vous qui
m'attendent
je vais m'incruster dans un bar à
hôtesse
faire une descente avec les stups
je dois assister à la grande parade des
flics
et je vais encore me retrouver sur une
scène de crime
[Musique]
ce soir j'ai rendez-vous dans le vieux
Manille en plein quartier rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui des bars à karaoké
et les filles très avenantes
officiellement la prostitution est
illégale aux Philippines mais ici elle
est à peine déguisée
[Musique]
il y aura 800 mille femmes qui se
prostituent dans ce pays presque une sur
60 un métier qui recrute chez les plus
pauvres j'arrive chez une sorte de
spécialiste un ancien proxénète surnommé
Dodon
est rangé des filles mais pas de tout il
lançait plus sur la prostitution qu'un
sociologue distingué
[Musique]
a grandi dans cette maison en plein
quartier rouge il est devenu Mac pour
gagner sa vie
je n'avais pas de travail le meilleur
moyen d'avoir de l'argent c'était
d'embaucher des filles des prostituées
j'avais 40 à 50 filles
ce que je peux dire c'est que ce n'était
pas beaucoup d'argent mais c'était de
l'argent très facile
pas beaucoup mais de l'argent facile
pourquoi avez-vous arrêté
parce que la police faisait toujours
descentes des raides
et puis la police me demandait de
l'argent il me disait maintenant tu nous
payes chaque semaine
c'était comme un péage hebdomadaire
chaque semaine je payais à chaque flic
30 euros alors fini c'est pour ça que
vous avez décidé d'arrêter
[Musique]
donne n'est plus Macron mais il connaît
encore le monde de la nuit il m'emmène
voir des filles celle qui travaille dans
la rue certaines sont ces anciennes
protégées
[Musique]
elles attendent des clients
elles sont jeunes
salut
j'ai du travail peut-être qu'il peut
choisir l'une de vous ça dépend de lui
quel âge as-tu
99 ans
travail depuis longtemps
tu aimerais faire un autre travail bien
sûr
demande-lui s'il veut tourner dans son
pays
trop brève rencontre
pour en savoir un peu plus sur la
condition des prostituées nous sommes
rentrés dans un club de nuit
mais impossible de filmer à l'intérieur
ou presque
il y a des dizaines de clubs de bar à
hôtesse à Manille celui-là est du genre
local pas vraiment pour les touristes
ici le quotidien du notes c'est
strip-tease intégrale faire voir les
clients et s'il y en a un qui a les
moyens 30 euros pour un extra
[Musique]
cœur cœur cœur cœur
nous avons dû nous éloigner du club pour
interroger Bing l'une des employés
Bing est une mama San une mère
maquerelle qui apprennent plusieurs
filles elle accepte de nous parler
malgré le risque
les gens de l'extérieur la seule chose
qu'ils savent sur ce club c'est qu'il y
a des filles qui dansent pour émoustier
les clients et officiellement elle ne se
déshabille pas complètement si la police
en tant qu'elles font autre chose elle
fera une descente
une fois la police a fait une rafle dans
notre club le patron a dû payer une
grosse amende
[Musique]
Bing nous emmène chez elle
elle habite dans un quartier populaire
de Manille près de l'université pas un
bidonville
[Musique]
chez elle Bing tue le temps buvant du
mauvais brandit avec sa barcada sa bande
de filles deux sont ses vrais filles les
autres se sont placés sous sa protection
certaines sont des travailleuses de nuit
d'autres pas difficiles de distinguer la
barcada une communauté d'intérêts sur
laquelle règne Bing du haut de ses 30
ans de métiers
[Musique]
quand ma mère est morte mes frères sont
partis en pension
il ne pouvait plus s'occuper de moi
j'avais 16 ans j'étais seule avec ma
sœur
donne-moi un coup à boire
mon père était avec une autre femme
[Musique]
il ne me donnait plus d'argent
alors j'ai cherché à en gagner moi-même
[Musique]
et c'est là que j'ai commencé à danser
Bing de danse plus aujourd'hui elle
s'occupe des filles protectrice mais
dure en affaires c'est elle qui négocie
les tarifs
c'est moi qui trouve les clients et
après j'appelle les filles
mais parfois c'est les filles qui
m'appellent et me disent ma main j'ai
besoin d'argent
trouve moi un client donne-moi un homme
la reine
la plus jeune de la bande elle a 14 ans
elle ne ressemble pas à une mère elle
aime bien être avec des jeunes et en
plus quand on a des problèmes on peut
compter sur elle
quand je l'amène avec moi je dis pas
touche elle n'a que 14 ans
avec elle les clients n'ont que le
plaisir de boire un verre pas plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même de jour Manille continue de
dévoiler ses côtés obscurs
j'ai rencard à l'agence antidrogue des
Philippines avec son directeur
Arthur au Cap d'Agde
l'agence antidrogue est une unité
d'élite directement rattachée à la
présidence 1800 agents contre une cible
principale le Chabou une métamphétamine
une sorte locale
Chabot le chabot c'est une drogue
chimique oui c'est une drogue chimique
[Musique]
aux Philippines on l'appelle la cocaïne
du pauvre
c'est la drogue la plus consommée dans
notre pays
et récemment nous avons intercepté des
mules
des transporteurs arrivant d'un pays
arabe
là a été arrêté avec 3,3 kg de Chabot et
le jour suivant un autre avec 2,9 kg de
Chabou
les agents Hydrox se préparent pour un
raid
l'objectif ne leur est révélé qu'au
dernier moment
un dealer de Chabot et ses complices ont
été localisés
voici les photos des personnes ciblées
comme vous avez déjà pu le voir pendant
l'opération
ils peuvent essayer de se mélanger à la
foule pour éviter d'être repérés
les agents antidrogues sont réputés
efficaces et incorruptibles un métier
dangereux contre les trafiquants et leur
puissants protecteurs
il croit il a quitté la police il y a 7
ans pour faire la guerre à la drogue une
question de foi
nous nous mettons sous la sainte
protection de Dieu Seigneur nous vous
demandons de nous guider et de nous
bénir pour cette opération nous prions
pour notre sécurité et pour être capable
d'accomplir notre mission
Seigneur nous vous remercions pour votre
bienveillance
nous nous offrons pour être ton
instrument dans le combat contre les
drogues illégales
au nom de Jésus-Christ notre Seigneur
une trentaine d'agents pour intervenir
en même temps dans deux maisons voisines
celle du dealer et celle de ses
complices
[Musique]
les trois personnes ciblées sont en
train de vendre de la drogue à des
chauffeurs de bus municipaux
donc la sécurité des usagers est
compromise
[Musique]
la rivière se voulait discrète mais l'un
des dealers les a repérés
là il y en a qui courent
[Musique]
pendant qu'un groupe investit une des
maisons l'autre intercepte le dealer qui
essaie de fuir
[Musique]
le chef du gang est capturé il est bien
connu sous le surnom d'apong
apprendre tu sais pourquoi tes voisins
t'ont dénoncé
et toi
c'est pas chez moi
dans l'autre maison de l'autre côté de
la rue les agents ont appréhendé deux
consommateurs des chauffeurs de bus
municipaux il risque jusqu'à 6 ans de
prison
les deux complices et sa femme baisse
n'ont opposé aucune résistance
mais les agents n'ont pas encore des
côtés de pièces à conviction
petite opération mais bon coup de pub
au moins la mission est accomplie ce
sont les trois dealers de cette zone
ils sont fichés dans notre base de
données
[Musique]
mission accomplie chef
pourquoi vous étiez ici vous
pour vous droguer non j'étais juste venu
manger un morceau
les chauffeurs de bus n'ont pas été
surpris en flagrant délit il nie pour
échapper à la prison
il n'avait pas encore fumé de drogue
nous sommes intervenus un peu trop tôt
les opérations tidrogues sont soumises à
un cadre légal très strict
deux fonctionnaires du ministère de la
Justice viennent pour tout vérifier elle
seule peuvent valider l'opération
mais les agents ont trouvé une douzaine
de sachets de Chabou
les revendeurs risquent jusqu'à 20 ans
de prison
[Musique]
tout indique que la drogue est consommée
dans cette maison
elle est préparée vendue et utilisé ici
l'épreuve sont soigneusement consignées
sous la surveillance des adjointes du
procureur
le moindre vice de procédure peut tout
faire capoter
les agents des stubs doivent aussi être
de soliduriste
à cause des risques et du danger
mais aussi à cause de la probabilité
d'être renvoyé pour des irrégularités ou
bien
une fois j'ai arrêté le fils d'un juge
de la Cour suprême
ils ont réussi à manipuler le système
légal
nous les gentils sommes devenus les
méchants
[Applaudissements]
je me suis relevé
il est dangereux de s'attaquer aux
puissants dans cette société
oligarchique 5% de la population possède
90% des richesses
entouré d'un océan de pauvreté les
privilégiés vivent protégés dans des
ghettos pour riches baptisés villages
exclusifs
Marlène et professeur de français à
Makati le quartier le plus riche de
Manille elle nous fait pénétrer dans son
village exclusif
quartier très privilégié parce que nous
sommes au centre de ma Cathy qui est le
centre de financier et commercial de
Philippines
[Musique]
donc on sort de la maison et puis nous
sommes près de tout c'est pour ça que
quand on dit ici village c'est pas le
village
les amours en France comme en France
c'est les villages et les communautés
qui sont enfermées par des Gates et des
clôtures et où il y a des gardes ça
donne un sens de sécurité
Marlène vit en sécurité mais elle aussi
subit le vrai fléau national la
corruption les Philippines le pays le
plus corrompu d'Asie et dans le peloton
de tête des plus corrompus du monde
c'est devenu un mode de vie la
corruption pour tout
pour avoir un certificat pour avoir une
attestation pour
obtenir un permis de ceci de cela et
pour que ça aille plus vite
il faut payer
donc il y a autant de corruption le pays
ne va pas avancer
la corruption mère de tous les crimes
même des plus horribles
il y a 20 ans dans ce village exclusif
de Manille a eu lieu le fait divers qui
a le plus marqué la société Philippe un
triple meurtre longtemps impuni
dans cette maison bourgeoise la nuit du
30 juin 1991 une mère et ses deux filles
son massacré à coups de couteau
le père absent cette nuit là survit
depuis 20 ans dans la douleur et le
souvenir
voici la chambre de Carmela
sa fille est née Carmela venait d'avoir
18 ans
elle a été violée puis poignardé à mort
la chambre de Jenifer Jennifer 6 ans tu
es de 11 coups de couteau dans le dos
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici que le crime s'est passé
elles étaient dans cette chambre cette
nuit-là
ma femme gisait sur le lit déjà morte
ma petite fille était là sur le côté
le massacre de la famille visconder
inspiré plusieurs films de fiction
si le traumatisme est si fort c'est que
les coupables sont des rejetons de la
jeunesse dorée une famille bourgeoise
assassinée par 9 gosses de riches
ivres de drogue de sexe et de sang
une bande menée par hubert-tweb le fils
d'un puissant sénateur
Hubert web échappera longtemps à la
justice
son père le sénateur protège son fils
grâce à son argent et ses relations il
fait nettoyer la scène de crime par des
policiers achetés fabriquent un alibi
pour uberte manipule les juges et tente
de discréditer les victimes
ils m'ont même accusé d'être
l'instigateur du massacre de ma famille
depuis le début la reviese Condé peut
compter sur le soutien sans faille de
d'intérimenez un militant contre la
corruption
il a aidé à faire enfin arrêter Hubert
web en août 95 4 ans après le massacre
grâce aux aveux tardifs d'une femme
Jessica Alfaro elle faisait partie du
groupe de tueurs le témoignage de
Jessica accable Hubert web
elle a dit la vérité elle a dit aux
enquêteurs qu'elle était prête à avouer
et quand elle a avoué ça a fait exploser
la défense des suspects
ils ont été jugés condamnés en première
instance condamné en appel et
malheureusement à cause de la corruption
la Cour suprême les a quittés
en décembre 2010 uber toi est libéré
après 15 ans de prison la Cour suprême
défiant l'évidence et l'opinion casse
les jugements antérieurs
ils sont la Cour suprême supposée être
la plus haute instance aux Philippines
je les maudis
dans les médias ils se sont retournés
contre moi
et aussi contre Monsieur vice Candé
car il les a accusés d'avoir touché
beaucoup d'argent
les riches quand ils sont accusés
suspectés ou condamnés sont bien traités
par le système judiciaire philippin
par se charger d'appliquer la loi par
les procureurs par les juges et même en
prison
nous aimerions faire changer le système
qui est trop corrompu
conduit une croisade personnelle contre
le crime
il a fondé son association il y a 20 ans
après l'assassinat de son frère tué par
des trafiquants de drogue
[Musique]
ça c'est juste au cas où on me suivrait
et j'ai aussi mon arme à feu
[Musique]
je la pose ici toujours
mes pires ennemis sont ceux que nous
avons déjà fait mettre en prison
and il y en a des centaines
on a fait emprisonner un gouverneur
un général
un ancien président
tellement de gens si puissants avant
je suis très prudent
avec deux personnes en tandem
je suis en alerte
je pourrais être la cible
le crime augmente à cause de la
corruption ils sont inséparables
ce sont les diables jumeaux de notre
société
[Musique]
une autre nuit d'enfer à Manille
et une autre scène de crime
je retrouve mon ami Benning le photo
reporter il est arrivé le premier sur
les lieux c'est lui qui m'a prévenu
de cadavres
deux jeunes gangster abattus par les
flics après un braquage dans une
fillette qui a réveillé tout le
voisinage
pas de quoi impressionner Belling
la première fois j'ai pas pu dormir
pendant trois nuits
la scène de crime et aussi tous ses
côtés sanglants
comme une chose ordinaire
pourtant cette scène de crimes n'est pas
si ordinaire j'apprends que deux autres
gangsters ont été emmenés à l'hôpital et
sont morts avant d'y arriver
et sans mettre plus loin il y a le
cadavre du 5e gangster de la bande
la police scientifique a du boulot tout
indique que les flics n'ont laissé
aucune chance de se rendre au gangster
mais ici personne ne les pleure de
Petits Braqueurs qui venaient d'un
bidonville leur tatouage certifie leur
appartenance à un gang
ils sont morts pour avoir volé deux
ordinateurs dans un magasin prise en
charge par 20 flics qui passaient par là
comme par hasard ça ressemble à une
embuscade
la police a une version toute prête pour
la presse
le propriétaire du magasin a attiré
l'attention des agents qui se sont
lancés à la poursuite des voleurs
les policiers leur ont couru derrière
c'était une patrouille normale en fait
aucun policier blessé heureusement ils
sont tous indemnes
moralité s'il y en a une
à Manille
mieux vaut être flic que gangster
ça ouvre des portes d'être journalistes
étrangers je suis l'invité d'honneur
d'un grand show policier une
démonstration de professionnels
Amani les flics comptent au moins le
sens du rythme un show bien rodé qui a
même prévu un rôle pour moi suspense
et là on me vient de me dire que je
serai un suspect ce n'est pas tout à
fait pareil pour l'intervention de la
police
[Musique]
mettez vos mains en évidence
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes en état d'arrestation vous
avez le droit de choisir un avocat si
vous ne pouvez pas vous en payer un
avocat sur la commune d'office vous avez
bien compris
bon je n'ai pas encaissé tout cela pour
rien je peux enfin approcher le général
Espinal le nouveau grand patron de la
police de Manille
le général espinat a été nommé il y a à
peine deux mois pour faire le ménage
dès son arrivée il a limogé le numéro 1
et le numéro 2 de la hiérarchie
policière pour corruption
[Musique]
qu'en est-il de la corruption on dit que
des officiers de police sont impliqués
dans la prostitution le trafic de drogue
c'est vrai
on étudie les rapports
de caractère et de personnalité
pour autant je tiens à vous le dire dans
mes 30 premiers jours j'ai renvoyé 34
policiers
tous les officiers de police doivent
respecter cette ligne
elle sépare les policiers des criminels
si vous franchissez cette ligne adieu je
saurai votre première ennemi
le général espinat n'est pas là pour
rigoler depuis qu'il a pris ses
fonctions deux fois plus d'armes ont été
saisies et la criminalité serait en
chute de 30%
. le général Espinasse c'est aussi
vendre ses résultats aujourd'hui
ne touchez pas aux armes avec vos
empreintes vous pourriez faire partie
des suspects
bien aussi j'aime les journalistes et
même
non non ok ok visez bien la cible
tellement les journalistes qu'elle leur
apprend à tirer les sages gratuits
me voilà TV5 la chaîne privée qui monte
à coup de programme centré sur la
criminalité
ici je vais comprendre pourquoi les
journalistes ont parfois besoin d'être
armés
en avant l'émission vedette c'est celle
des frères tulfo Raphaël Ben et Erwin
ils animent un choc quotidien et en
direct la spécialité des frères tulfaux
asticoter les puissants dénoncer les
bavures de la police et la corruption
des élites
[Musique]
on nous a apporté une plainte contre un
maire de quartier un maire qui a une
conception très particulière des
sanctions contre ces administrés au lieu
de suivre la voie judiciaire il frappe
lui-même ce qui troublent l'ordre public
au téléphone qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
voilà ce qui s'est passé quelqu'un a
jeté un vélo sur le pare-brise d'un
triporteur et ses disputé avec le
chauffeur je me suis interposé mais
celui qui a jeté le vélo m'a insulté il
m'a traité de fils de [ __ ]
alors je vais gifler
Monsieur le Maire ce n'est pas la
première fois que vous agressez vos
administrés
plusieurs témoins ont dit que ça s'est
déjà produit à de nombreuses reprises
que ce n'est pas bien ce ne sera pas
nécessaire de prolonger la discussion
une erreur ça se corrige
mais comment c'est lui qui m'a insulté
le maire je ne veux plus entendre de
nouvelles plaintes contre vous sinon je
viendrai moi-même vous voir
[Musique]
plutôt direct le style des frères tu le
faut entre justiciers cathodique et
inquisiteur citoyen ce qui n'est pas
sans risque
sur pas mal de politiciens déjà pour
corruption
je n'arrive plus à compter combien on en
a fait renvoyer ou jetés en prison pour
avoir touché des peaux de vin pour abus
[Musique]
danseuse de faire ce métier au
Philippines
vous savez beaucoup de journalistes
philippins ont été tués pour avoir
enquêté sur des activités illégales
les ont été abattus
c'est vraiment la jungle ici
il n'y a que peu de journalistes qui ont
le courage d'aller aussi loin
il y a un prix pour ça on peut se
prendre une balle ou un coup de couteau
c'est la rançon pour dire la vérité
expose
nous sommes les frères qui avons le
courage de dire
la sécurité ça fait donc partie de notre
vie
une voiture blindée des gardes du corps
plutôt sympa le métier de journaliste à
Manille voilà mon meilleur ami ma femme
ma première femme
vous voulez voir ma deuxième femme
elle est là
[Musique]
ma dernière nuit à Manille et encore un
rendez-vous dans un coin paumé
aux côtés d'une escouade de police
j'attends
Erwin Duffo
Erwin est sur un coup il a convoqué les
flics pour faire arrêter des joueurs
illégaux
et il va filmer tout cela pour son
émission
on a prévenu leur supérieur
on leur a dit qu'on avait une info sur
des jeux illégaux dans ce secteur
comment avez-vous eu cette information
sur les jeux c'est un habitant qui nous
a appelé
les gens savent qu'on fait ce genre de
boulot
[Musique]
l'objectif le voici une fête foraine je
m'attendais plutôt à un tripo clandestin
mais ici tous les jeux ne sont pas
innocents
quelques forains sont embarqués pour
avoir fait parier de l'argent
pas vraiment des fortunes mais ici c'est
interdit
c'est qui votre chef
je ne connais que son prénom Édouard
vous savez très bien que ce n'est pas
correct c'est interdit en vertu de la
loi
[Musique]
dans cette ambiance de fête foraine il y
a plein d'enfants
de l'argent ils vont doubler tripler
leur mise
ils ne se rendent pas compte que c'est
illégal
ça arrive souvent dans des petits
carnavals comme ça dans des coins comme
ici
pourquoi les gens préfèrent-ils vous
appeler vous plutôt que la police
peut-être parce que la police locale est
achetée elle touche sa part
Erwin gagne 20 000 dollars par mois et
paye très bien ses équipes pour éviter
toute tentation quant aux flics ils
viennent d'un autre district et sont des
dommages et
c'est important d'avoir filmé l'action
de la police
si je l'avais fait que les prévenir ici
ils auraient rouvert les stands demain
maintenant qu'ils savent que ça passe à
la télé c'est fermé pour toujours
nous trouverons probablement un autre
endroit
des jeux interdits qui rouvriront
ailleurs des policiers intéressés aux
résultats quelques forains en prison ou
comment Amani se fabrique une bonne
émission de télévision
[Musique]
j'ai une dernière visite à faire avant
de partir et j'espère bien que c'est une
simple visite
[Musique]
Billy bid City jail la plus grande
prison des Philippines
renferme 13.000 prisonniers dont les
pires criminels du pays une quarantaine
d'islamistes deux généraux et une
poignée de politiciens
sécurité maximum
au moins pour rentrer
mais dès l'enceinte franchit surprise
Billy bid ne ressemble à aucune de nos
prisons ça a tout l'air d'un village de
vacances
plus de portes pas un gardien en vue des
dollars qui vagues à leurs occupations
et se baladent tranquille avec moins de
200 gardiens pour plus de 13000 détenus
la prison fonctionne sur le mode
autogestion
les taulards ont même un taulier une
sorte de chef du village feuilles un
ancien flic qui a pris 15 ans pour
kidnapping
feuille est chargée de maintenir
l'équilibre entre les droits et les deux
devoirs des prisonniers
[Musique]
bien sûr nos familles nous rendent
visite ça nous aide
elles peuvent venir chaque week-end
nos femmes et nos enfants peuvent même
rester dormir
est-ce qu'il y a des incidents ici de la
violence tout le monde ici même moi est
obligé d'obéir aux règles
se respecter les uns les autres
respecter les visiteurs respecter la
direction
les gardiens les croyances de chacun
si tu respectes ces règles tu ne
rencontres aucun problème
si tu désobéis tu auras de sérieuses
ennuis
avec un marché des restaurants des
écoles des salles de sport de jeux et de
concert
[Musique]
s des ateliers tous les lieux de culte
il y a de quoi ici mieux supporter
l'enfermement
[Musique]
ici les prisonniers riches ceux qui sont
soutenus par du riches familles doivent
partager
ils ne savent pas laver leurs vêtements
ou cuisiner
s'ils veulent avoir quelqu'un qui
travaille pour eux ils doivent le
nourrir au moins lui donner de l'argent
ça se passerait très mal pour eux s'ils
ne partagaient pas
et ça marche vraiment
on apprend à s'aimer les uns les autres
à ne pas se faire de mal
une communauté d'amour égalitaire et
solidaire dire qu'il aura fallu que
j'aille en prison pour voir Manille sans
crime ni violence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec la pauvreté la corruption c'est sûr
cette ville n'en a pas fini avec la
criminalité mais ici j'ai vu du courage
de l'espoir de la joie de vivre
salut Manille je te connais maintenant
tu vaux bien mieux que ta réputation
je reviendrai
[Musique]